South Africa has 306 new political parties.
The 2024 elections are speculated to be on May 22nd
and everyone is asking the 350 ran question,
who should we vote for?
Well, thanks to a new government gazette
which has published 30 new political parties
which will be contesting the general elections.
Let's take a look at some of these new parties
and laugh at their crackhead attempts
at reaching Parliament.
First off, we have the gap fixes of South Africa
LED by the father of the P s cells,
B B L middlefielder
SBU Mpisani,
who wants to fix the gap
by eradicating the tender system.
I'm sure many in K Z N will love that.
Moving onwards,
we have the South African Rainbow Alliance
LED by the former speaker of the city of Joburg,
Coleen Makubela.
Sara is a political Bloc consisting of small parties
who no one would vote for
now coming together to not be voted for.
We also have the Unemployed National Party,
the African Unemployed Congress,
Citizens Change South Africa,
Save South Africa,
South African Order Leadership,
the prophetic freedom movement
whose tagline
and I shit you not
is stop the 6, 6,
6 and our last hope.